[Applause]
welcome back
i i look every guest that i've had thus
far starting with jeffrey gundlach has
been a delight
but i have to say it again you're in for
a real real
treat today i cannot tell you how
excited i am to be here with my fishing
buddy
my good friend constance hunter she is
chief economist at kpmg
and uh we're coming to you from
fojo and i'm gonna have to
have you educate me one more time so
take me back to
why you know this area of
new york so it stems back to the 80s
um this neighborhood it was not
gentrified new york in the 80s
and a fojo this neighborhood was
photographers and hookers and it's where
the models came and did shoots in
studios like this one
for all the fashion magazines and all
the catalogs that got produced here in
new york and there's
if you walk around this neighborhood
you'll still see a lot of photography
studios like print where you can get
large form
prints made but it was you know
pre-gentrification
so you also had in the evening hours you
had evidently a lot of hookers walk out
i know i was here a lot of hookers
walking the streets well we know you
weren't one of the hookers but you were
one of the models i was one of the
models
how was i mean how explain that
transition
well you know i uh i was going to school
here at nyu
and um i had been doing some
modeling in philadelphia where i grew up
and did a lot of runway
actually so there's there's actually a
ton of like sort of small
conversations on the catalog i'd love it
and
uh you know it was great it was great
money it was great money i wanted the
money to start investing
and that's what i did i i started
investing
my my modeling money and you know i
traveled and visited friends and
of course i was a young woman in new
york i bought shoes
right before carrie bradshaw yep even
came to the screen
um yeah i had a similar disease
but you know it was in it it's a very
you know it's a business and it was so
interesting as i always looked at it as
a business
and so it it and you know the
interesting thing about modeling right
there are these gorgeous girls like
beautiful and i'm very much girl next
door right
and so you know you become hum it was
humbling
it was very it was very humbling
experience right but you start to
realize what's
what is your market segment right so
it's
you know it's i was already using my
sort of customer
yet nascent economist brain right in
sort of figuring out like what is this
what is this business
what makes it tick what you know so
why economics how economics when did you
know you wanted
but was this did you like kindergarten
in philadelphia and you're like
i want to grow up and be an economist
one day no i actually i wanted to be an
interior decorator
and i literally when i tell you so this
is pre-computers of course and i can't
when i tell you i can't draw
i can't draw a straight line on graph
paper like it is bad
bad bad now you're a ruler after today
no it's not gonna help
like i trust trust me um but
uh and my my mother sort of introduced
me to a friend of hers who was a graphic
designer so i could learn
like she was trying to steer me and my
parents are kind of like but you're good
at math why would you
be and so anyway it's okay not not to
disparage interior designers it's great
an important profession
sure but um i also had very very one of
my best friends growing up
her dad was reading this this is the 80s
and japan was buying
all of our real estate real estate and
he was reading a book called the coming
economic war with japan
and was talking to me about it and i
must have been
15 you know and and so he said i'll lend
you the book after i'm done reading it
and i was so fascinated with the idea
that you could have an economic war i'm
like what is an economic war oh yeah
right
and so i started reading the book and
i'm like this is actually kind of i mean
of course
like probably 90 of it went over my head
right but this was like the plaza hotel
i mean they were buying up
i think it was i think it was
rockefeller center okay it was
rockefeller central now my dad
was in finance and and when i was a
kid he would come home from work and
read the wall street journal the back
page
read all the stock quotes oh yeah and so
he taught me when i was seven or eight
you know how to read what's a p e
ratio what's you know uh which price to
book
all the ratios that were in the back of
the wall street journal so i did grow up
in an environment
where you know i was i was aware of what
was happening in terms of investing to
some extent but
you know from a kid's lens right oh yeah
no i mean that's
we've got that in common i mean i was i
was always surrounded by my father's
wall street journals
but by the same token i was different
than you i i grew up saying i'll
never go into economics and finance
which of course when once you say never
that means that that's where you're
going
so when i lived in new york i
would once the market closed because i
was buying way too many shoes
way too many shoes so i put myself in
the corner
and i sent myself back to school
so the stock market would close and i
would race to the west side go way
uptown
and i got my second masters at columbia
what made you choose colombia and and
talk about i mean for me it was a
magical experience
oh yeah and that campus is just magical
it's matt it's
why colombia so i went to the school of
international public affairs
and i knew so what's interesting and i
think it was again reading this book
so i had i didn't know that there was
any other kind of economics but
international economics right so to me
after starting thinking what what what
the spark was this idea that japan was
investing all this money in the us and
somehow that was a bad thing
which i think was misguided but we'll
get into that later
um so it so i wanted to do international
economics and so i looked at all of
those schools
whether it's you know kennedy school
seis princeton the woodrow wilson school
and cepa at columbia school of
international public affairs and
i love new york i just i love new york
i and in in terms of you know the
professors that they had all the adjunct
professors that were
uh you know actually practicing real
world real world
in combination with with the sort of
brilliant faculty that they have
um so it's it was just
it was i was great that i i was so
thrilled that i got in and that i was
able to go to cepa and i'm still very
active
in the alumni network and and it's just
a great it's
it's been a great um it was a great
experience then but having that
family of alumni around the world
is wonderful yeah i'm crossing fingers
that one of mine
chooses to uh to apply to colombia
speaking of one of mine
so i have three boys and one girl and uh
they they two of the the two older at
culver military academy
the two youngest are probably a year
away or so
and i've been trying to talk her into
horses for years because culver has the
biggest equestrian program
really good equestrian program all the
military schools do
and she says no horses but you do not
say no horses i mean
you're in the city but
i this is my third time back in the city
you haven't been coming to the city a
lot either no
you've been on long island for a long
time with your horse
yes yes it's been great i've been i you
know
prior to covet if i got to ride two or
three times a week it was great
right i'd make it out there on the
weekends yeah try to work one day from
there if i could
and so being able to be there during the
whole pandemic
um it's been fabulous i've been able to
ride you know more like five days a week
which has been
we're gonna pop a picture of her horse
up here shortly so
um so anyway uh yeah it's great and
and i've i rode um as a kid and i think
it's a
you know it's one of those things um
it's and we joke with the people i ride
with we joke about it how it's literally
it's almost an addiction they're so
therapeutic
and when you're a good writer you forget
that they're therapeutic so i'm also on
the board
of a charity here in new york called
gallup nyc
that does therapeutic horseback riding
for new yorkers with disabilities
and we do everything from autism to
you know ms to cerebral palsy we have a
veterans program
and the change and the healing that
these animals bring to people
is just it's just magic and so i don't
need therapy
right it's my exercise my therapy
my spiritual renewal my meditation all
and one is
you're outside you get fresh air and
they're just
they're just amazing animals i mean
they're just incredible
so um i've i've never asked you this
question i know how
i met david kotak i was just i was a
newbie at the fed we met at a bca
conference
i mean years ago how did you so david
kotak
uh hosts camp kotak every summer
has since right after 9 11 and um
constance and i are one of the few women
one of the early women and right like
because he realized he needed to sort of
invite some women well there was a cnbc
producer who was like what is this the
masters where there's no women up here
in the woods
so and you can tell because some of the
guys went off into the woods and that
they were not
they went off and voted and you can you
you could tell that first summer who
voted against
letting women come to camp coachup but
that's how we that's how we met yes you
know
basically in canoes fishing but how do
you mean how did you meet
uh i'm very involved with the national
association for business economics i
actually just
rolled off as as president of the
organization and david
um you know spent a spent a lifetime
being an active member
and so in typical david fashion of
course um
he would organize a dinner uh and so you
you'd go to nabe and he'd he'd already
reserved you know some restaurant with a
big
table or a private room to get people
together to bring people together
and yeah and so um
i think he sort of approached me and
said you know you asked a really good
question in that session would you like
to come what are you doing for dinner
and i
was i i was young i mean it was you know
was in
it was in the early 2000s late 90s and i
said sure
i'll come to your dinner right and it
was fabulous
it was and one thing led to another and
then and led to fishing yeah when then
then eventually i got
i got the you know we were bringing to
camp kotak you want to come
and we're going to do two weeks this
year because everybody's so excited to
get
back i know well and we have to stagger
the groups right i think that's another
this is this is new i have to confess to
you i'm i'm not big on fishing
i i wasn't going to bring that up i knew
that i mean i love
being in the boat and i love chatting
and i loved
we we drink wine oh yeah talk so that's
a fun thing it's a day drinking thing
day drinking and fishing but um but i
but i love
david that much and the the fellowship
and the community of people
is so that's how good it is that i'm
willing to spend three or four days
doing something that's
probably not one of my top activities
yeah um shout out to j.r i will you ever
forgive me for catching that eel
probably not um okay so
let's let's get down to economics
um we're in a unique
truly unique time in u.s history 34
of income is attributable to
government transfers we've never pumped
this kind of money
into the u.s economy not even during
world war ii
uh it was pumped in different directions
right it was pumped into the military
industrial complex and this is being
pumped into households
and it's a different distribution
mechanism
so here we are and
when you have that kind of extraordinary
level of
stimulus you create some imbalances
and you call it disequilibrium yeah so
this is your this is your latest report
walk us through
how we got to this state and
again how how unique the economy is
right now
i suspect we would have been in this
disequilibrium even if we hadn't have
given the supplemental
unemployment insurance right um now that
that certainly increases it because it
increased demand at a time when you'd
normally have demand
right decline we've had no household
credit cycle so
but wait it's amazing i mean it's just
incredible and and
and in the long run that could prove i
mean this is an interesting experiment
we always joke in economics there are no
natural experiments right
we're having a very interesting
experiment right now
and we'll see how it works out because i
think there will be less scarring coming
out of this recession than a normal
recession
i also think we are we are many people
are anchoring to the previous recession
where there was so much scarring
and we pro and we probably wouldn't have
had that much scarring anyway in this
recession because we didn't have a
credit crash
right it came out of nowhere and just
sort of smashed us
and so we're in this disequilibrium for
several reasons right so if you think of
a if you think of a typical and we're
going to we're thinking we're going to
put up a graphic if you look at this
we're going to put a demand curve right
so what happened is
we've had uh people that have been able
to work and still have their jobs
haven't been able to spend right they
weren't able to spend on services
the you know everything from going to
the dentist to getting your hair cut to
going to a concert to going to a
sporting event
couldn't do it and so you had a build up
of savings from the people who are
working
then you had a build up of savings from
people receiving government money
right and some of the we had a big pay
down
of of revolving credit right so so
people
you know household balance sheets are
strong and what people shifted to was
demanding goods
and goods that would make their
experience of being at home
more enjoyable i think i read that 57
percent of home
u.s homeowners now on the fire pit
did remodeling of some kind yes 57 it's
a huge number
huge number well because you're there
all the time and you start to notice
what's wrong or you have to work from
home
so we you know we had to reconfigure
some rooms in our house so we could work
from home and
you know on a regular because i had a
chair i had this
antique wooden chair at my desk because
i would work from home maybe
three or four days a month maybe
probably more like three
and prior to the pandemic and so i would
sit in the wooden chair no big deal
after a month and a half of the pandemic
my back was killing me i was like
what am i doing and my husband's like
yeah what are you doing in that chair
like you need to get a wheelchair
because this is not a three day
situation here so
in any case um we saw this huge demand
for goods
and so normally what would happen is
you'd see the supply curve
move down and to the right greater
quantity being produced
prices would normalize right and and
that's what you'd have in a normal
situation but because of the pandemic
we had constraints in supply of all
sorts of things so this is intermediate
goods the chair you name it we have
we've
supply constraints and because we've had
rolling
um case waves around the world right
we're seeing this continue
to impact the supply chain and so
instead of moving down into the right
the supply curve now has moved up and to
the left
and so we now have more quantity being
demanded of certain goods
and but we and the price is higher and
it we call this this disequilibrium this
is
not where you would see the supply curve
move
if we were not still being impacted by
the pandemic
in global supply chains are there signs
that it is
i'm i'm thinking of regional fed surveys
where six months out
so future inventories future delivery
times
they're finally starting to come off
their highs
but future current is still you need a
bigger scale
but are there are you starting to see
signs of a let up
i think yes but and there's there's a
couple things that are happening
simultaneously the first thing that's
happening
is that you know we have a saying in
economics nothing cures high prices like
high prices you know people are saying
ah
maybe i won't build that you know
deck on the back of my house because now
it's going to cost me 20
more 40 more because lumber prices went
up now we're starting to see
more lumber being produced i think by
the time we get to the
third or fourth quarter we're not going
to have the situation we have now
they're they're cranking up sawmills and
georgia and everywhere yes and canada
which
which now here's an interesting thing so
if you look at and this is in the chart
book if you look at
what happened in 2019 when we put
tariffs on canadian lumber
you saw this fall in employment in in
the canadian lumber mills
you had coveted hit so that decline just
kept going yep
then you see all of a sudden the hiring
is just a v
straight back up because you had this
massive demand here from the u.s but
it's still not back to the pre-tariff
levels
so you know like in everything it's the
perfect storm that gets you
right yep it's so we had we you know
there are a number of sort of
odd perfect storm situations that are
compounding and interacting
with the supply constraints of covid
you've got chilean
miners going on strike in the middle of
copper going through the roof and you're
like
what was that headline now now they're
going on strike well that's when they go
on strike you go on strike
strikes are usually a sign of a stronger
labor market
yeah you can demand more yeah and
they're saying we want to we want our
piece of that higher copper price
right but getting back to this situation
of will it ease up
so two things are happening one demand
is going to come off a little bit
because of these higher prices so that
will it that will
that will help the easing up and then i
think we're gonna see supply
start to normalize you know in the
probably latter part of the third
quarter fourth quarter and into the
first and second quarter of next year
where to
we could be at a situation where many of
these commodities actually
see prices turned down well we're
beginning
to see and there's i mean they're well i
meant on a year over year but yeah yeah
significant but i mean you know i don't
think many people realize
and you're a student of international
economics
how much supply china's sitting on
and i just i i don't i don't think
they're factoring in that
china is the world's largest steel
producer by a factor of 10
over the next next largest which is
india which is clearly offline right
clearly offline um but that whole
idea uh that
preceded kovid this idea of
deglobalization
i i think if anything and you can give
me your views
i think the idea of d globalization has
been debunked
well so we certainly see how global the
world is with
covid but here's the fascinating thing i
mean and i talk to ceos
pretty much every week um we started a
uh an event at kpmg where we where
once a week we invite you know eight to
ten ceos and we call it cocktails with
constance we
we send them a nice beverage of their
choice i'm a ceo
you call me i'm kidding and and we we
have a conversation and so this this con
you know and i give them a bit of an
economic update and and it's been
you know a wonderful thing because i
feel like i've learned as much from
them as probably they've learned from me
maybe i've even learned more
and so what um what i'm hearing is
you are here people are bringing stuff
back to the u.s so there is
someone was telling me that there is a
mill that produces nits in lancaster
pennsylvania that has been shuttered for
years and it's somebody is seeing that
it makes sense to reopen it
right so i i think i think
i think deglobalization is never gonna
fully happen
but it is it is interesting to see
you do have anecdotes and those
anecdotes can add up to data
right i mean they don't always right
that we always say the plural of
anecdotes is not data but
but you hear enough of them and then you
start to look for it in the data to see
if it's confirmed but we're starting to
see
people bringing stuff back just because
they need to produce now
and and so the the economics are there
for that to work
i do think we're still i mean look we
have such global specialization
and i mean look at look at what's
happening with semiconductors
yeah i mean we're and unfortunately
well and we actually export almost as
many semiconductors as we import
that's the fascinating thing when you
when people don't understand the data
the difference between what we export
and and what a foundry is they're like
it's all taiwan taiwan i'm like no no no
no explain this the semiconductor well
i'm gonna i i'm not an expert on
semiconductors right so so
it's sort of like i feel like sometimes
my job is like how quickly can you
you know teach yourself information yeah
right how like what do you
how deep is your network because you
need people to call right
who are experts and then you need to
really delve into the data and then
confirm that you're understanding the
data correctly so i think there are
again there are a number of things
happening prior to covid
the anticipation within the
semiconductor industry was like okay
we're going to 5g
right and so there was a buildup of
chips for the purpose of 5g
but the thing that happened with kovid
and you can actually see this in the
data the increased purchases
of computer equipment it is literally
a straight shot up in the nipa accounts
which is the national
income and product accounts which you
which is where we get gdp from
you never see that i mean it is
phenomenal so what happened was because
of covid
demand for computing went up
dramatically people bought
you know home entertainment systems i'm
not a gamer but they bought
all those things to do gaming i know
they did i know our household did
and and so you had all of a sudden this
shift in the demand for chips that
everybody
thought we weren't going to need as many
of these over the next year yeah it
wasn't just work from home it was study
from home yeah
so the kids i mean study from home
entertain from home
everything do it all from home so that
again another perfect storm situation
that that sort of compounded with the
with the intermittent shutdowns and then
if you look at our imports in the second
quarter our imports of semiconductors
are down almost two and a half times
more than they are
you know because they fluctuate right
every quarter sure but we saw a big
decline so
so here the anticipation was well we
don't we can't
they canceled all their orders like
there were no imports the automakers
were like we're not going to sell cars
exactly and then the demands just
increased significantly and we've kind
of caught back footed
that two will normalize i think it's
going to take a little longer probably
until
the first or second quarter of next year
but that that too will normally but it's
coming it's coming yeah
well and what i'd like to say you know
what people push back of course on
economists and say transitory it's not
transitory i'm like
let me just transitory doesn't mean not
disruptive
right it is extremely disruptive
but it's not going to last forever right
this is
not necessarily going to last forever
but if that doesn't mean it's
not extremely disruptive and probably
holding back growth a little bit this
year
if we weren't having these supply chain
bottlenecks in these price increases
so supplemental benefits
look to be finely ending yeah and in
some states more than others
in 20 states and counting true including
texas
texas was the big one being from texas i
was i was curious it's a big state
yeah it's the second most populous state
so i was curious to see because in the
initially when the governors were
starting to give the money back it was
smaller states
like utah has like a 2.9 unemployment
rate i mean they desperately needed
everybody and anybody to come off the
sidelines
well we don't know that this is going to
bring people off the sidelines and again
look as an economist
this is a fabulous natural experiment so
we have a map
in the chart book which shows the
vaccination rates
by states and interestingly enough
i'm going to say about 45
to 60 i'm not exactly a bit have to look
at the map but
and sort of you know population weight
it but let's just say somewhere
around 45 to 60 percent of those
impacted are in the lowest vaccination
states
and we know that the jobs that need to
come back are all work from your job
site jobs they're not the work from home
jobs the unemployment rate if you work
from home
is three percent right that's already a
very tight labor market
yeah and like all the manufacturing jobs
that are open are for low skilled
workers
people don't it's it's not the same
skills mismatch that we've had in prior
downturns
i yeah to some extent i mean that's
that's a whole
yeah but you bring up a good point
that's that's
that's a factor but what i was gonna say
is so if you have the jobs that need to
come back
or work from your job site jobs and you
live in a state that just hasn't been
rolling out vaccinations as
in as fast is it possible that some of
these people aren't going back to work
because they're concerned about their
health
right or they haven't been vaccinated
and of course they have the luxury to
have that concern because they were
receiving the supplemental unemployment
benefits
but i think these two things may be
interacting so it'll be very interesting
to see
what the result is and i also think
covet changed people's preferences
right they changed it changed and it
changed people's concept of time
so when we look at a historic uh
analysis of something like a
supplemental unemployment insurance
historically it was considered not to
hold people back from working because
you knew it wasn't going to last forever
right you're you're still having skills
atrophy
you know they're you know people enjoy
some many facets of work in addition to
getting the money and getting your
paycheck like sure you have
your social interaction you're making a
difference in the world you're
you know there's a lot of things to be
proud of that people you know there's a
lot of value in working
besides just earning the money right so
so it was always assumed that this
wouldn't really
significantly hold back employment but i
think during covet people's
preferences has changed and their sense
of time has changed
right so even though they know yeah it's
ending in four months
it's just four months maybe a different
perception to people
under covet and after a year of lockdown
than
than it was prior to the pandemic well
so there's also
there's also this anger factor and i i
pick it up on my twitter feed
all the time well twitter is a magnet
for anger but it true
and i'm there look i'm on twitter with
you but but it is sort of a magnet for
anything the
power to the people and and and you've
written about this
i mean again talking about real time
experiments i don't know that we know
what their ramifications will be of how
very k-shaped
this recovery has been and the and the
idea with the targeted fiscal response
was to make it less k
shaped right to to try to alleviate the
um
difficulty and hardship for the people
at the bottom of the k
um which honestly if they hadn't have
done i really think we would
people would be so angry because if you
are in the upper portion of the k
you're more likely to have you're more
likely to have a college education which
means you're more likely to earn more
money
which means you're more likely to have a
house and have higher equity in your
house
you're more likely to have wealth and
household savings and we know
all what's happened to assets during
this
during this pandemic right houses houses
have gone up you're my former employer
right equities have gone up in value
mm-hmm lots of you know
and they're working from home they have
the luxury of being
comfortably separated if you will as
opposed to
not having that optionality yeah but i i
i i it will be
interesting to see what happens i think
after september
well because of the k because i did a
hundred percent
i think um when we get people if we can
continue to make progress on
vaccinations though and we can really
eradicate
covid we are in a situation
where i think we could have a decade of
really
interesting strong growth because if you
think about it
this is your productivity this is my
productivity argument so we've had it
we've had an acceleration
of of transmission of technology
throughout the economy again like i was
mentioning
all of that computer equipment
investment and software investment and r
d investment
when we talk to our clients when i talk
to ceos they are
all undertaking digital transformations
within their organizations
um we are on the cusp of really seeing
artificial intelligence and machine
learning really become what we would
call a general purpose
technology and once that happens once
that's harnessed
um you're going to see the opportunity
for productivity gains so i think
over the and when we compare this period
to the period just after world war
ii right it was we were mentioning we
haven't had fiscal stimulus like this
but during world war ii
and my mother used my mother told
stories about being on the jersey shore
during the war and they had to leave all
they didn't have any street lights on
they'd have all their shades down
because there were u-boats off the coast
and they didn't want to
give any clues to where the shoreline
was
and and so we had a lockdown of sorts
all along the eastern seaboard
so people weren't going out at night
spending money on recreation if they
you know and so we had a build-up of
savings we had gis sending money home
um so again this buildup of savings
helped
fund a whole bunch of consumption and a
whole bunch of investment following
world war ii
so right out of world war ii when we
were transitioning from
um military industry to civilian
industry
the assumption was we'd have a huge
recession that that transition was going
to be horrible and difficult
and painful and it turned out in part
because of the savings
that helped fuel this consumption and
fuel investment
but the gi bill also sent an entire
generation to people to college which
improved our productivity
so here we have a different situation
where i think we have an education
deficit as a result of this right and
and we have it
obviously in our for our school age um
population but i think we've got a lot
of moms at home
too yeah and we're out of the workforce
we and we have it for our young adults
that are joining our companies
right so they're not integrating and
learning um
about the company we don't have
corporate culture though it's going to
be harder to it's harder to maintain
corporate culture
in an environment like this so so
there's going to be some catch-up and
some investment that's going to be
needed in education
across all levels of the economy but if
we can really do that
then then i think we have the the
makings of
of a possibly very um significant
productivity boost and when i say
significant i'm talking about 75 basis
points higher a year
50 basis for entire years considering
the base right
and you compound that over a decade it's
a really
it could really be um a very very
interesting
well there's also you know a decade
david kotak
brings this up from time to time
we've also taken a lot of the least
efficient players
out of the system at least initially
there was
a mini bankruptcy wave certainly not
the fed stepped in and prevent it but
but he he does talk often about
survivorship bias
that that call it the if it goes from
the s p
500 theoretically to the s p 400
that those are going to be 400 lean mean
companies
because they've had to fight their way
through this well you know this is this
concept of anti-fragility
right and we know we're humans are
anti-fragile but but a lot of our
organizations a lot of our institutions
are anti-fragile
and it sort of ties back to creative
destruction right
what doesn't kill you makes you stronger
and necessity is the mother of invention
are really coming to bear here and like
and so these are leaner meaner companies
and they are stronger and they did
engage in digital
investment during this time period
because they had to
to to survive so but you bring up uh
you bring i mean prior to the pandemic
mckinsey came out with a
study that said that by 2030 i want to
say by 2030 yeah
like a third of u.s jobs will be
automated that's been
expedited so you know sir the oxford
oxford came out with the initial study i
think in 2015 and they said that by 2025
50 of us jobs would be gone again
due to automation and they were using
this fabulous database from the
the bureau of labor statistics the o net
database which
categorizes all different skills of
workers and
it was groundbreaking research but it
was dead wrong
right and what we found is that yes
automation does
take away some jobs but it adds other
jobs and
what we see is the best automation is
the automation that helps you do your
job better
right so let me i'm going to give you an
interesting example
and it ties back to something you
mentioned about women which i do want to
touch on with you
so we obviously this gender pay gap in
in some fields there is an economist at
harvard claudia golden who did a lot of
research on this with larry katz two
prominent labor economists and they
compared pharmacists
to attorneys so in pharmacy
if you are a woman and let's say you
choose to work you have children you say
you know i'm going to work 25 hours a
week instead of 40 hours a week
you make the same per hour as the
pharmacist working 40 hours a week
why because of artificial intelligence
because
they you pharmacies now use a lot of
technology
to assist the pharmacists there's
greater substitutability between
pharmacists a and pharmacist b so if i
go to the pharmacy i don't care if i get
pharmacist a or pharmacist b
right it doesn't matter to me i get my
prescription filled they have the data
they have the information they have sure
right they can help me it doesn't matter
which one you're a lawyer i'm going to
go to a law firm
i don't want to get a lawyer a or lawyer
b i want lawyer a that i build a
relationship with i want lawyer a that
my friend referred to me because i know
lawyer a worked on a similar case
i want lawyer a because they've been
working with my company for
for 15 years and they know intricacies
and details that i don't need to tell
them
every single thing in order for them to
do their job well so inc
in professions where relationships are
really important
where learning by doing is really
important there is a
pay gap between those people who work
fewer hours and and and greater hours
right so if you're a lawyer working 25
hours
a week versus a lawyer working well it's
law so let's call it
35 hours versus 70 hours exactly right
you're the 35 hour a week lawyer
and you have the 70-hour week lawyer
you're not making the same per hour
you're making less per hour and that
wedge grows the longer
that gap is there because of the
learning by doing you're not making as
many relationships
right you're not learning as much so if
we can use artificial intelligence
to help augment the knowledge that
lawyers have
now there's not still you're still the
relationship component right of course
but you you increase to some extent the
substitutability
and you increase the ability to have
more flexibility in your work
so maybe a female lawyer who's taken
some time off
for her family and is working 25 hours a
week that gap
between that lawyer and the 70 hour a
week lawyer
might not be as great if you have really
good artificial intelligence to help you
do your job
so i i throw this out there so there's
there's trade-offs right we say in
economics there are no answers only
trade-offs right
and and look in any trade-off there's
going to be
some some negative aspects right so it's
not a panacea but i don't know that it's
as terrible as what we think dooms say
or say and by the way
we when we've had in in previous history
when we've had automation what's always
happened
is we have created jobs that we never
knew
needed to be done or that that are a
byproduct of that new technology
we didn't have middle management wasn't
a thing until we could have automated
factories where you suddenly needed to
have administration occur
for the business right so there were all
this middle management came about
because of automation that wasn't a
career track
in the 1850s true
right but it was a career track in the
1950s
so um you mentioned women so
and i always get get a rap from
the the occasional single father who
stays at home with the kids
but mr mom but generally speaking
working moms have really gone through
the ringer
in this pandemic well sure and so so
a working parent who is the primary who
is
who who is focusing on their children
right
it doesn't matter if you're a man or a
woman the thing is is that
what what happened in this recession if
you look at the profession the
the sectors that were most impacted
right it was
sectors that mostly employ women health
care so nurses
um it was education education
and it was leisure and hospitality all
fields that mostly employ
women so we saw a much greater impact
um to women in this recession now we've
had previous recessions right
that where where impacted construction
where it impacted manufacturing where it
mostly impacted men so the story
you know coming out of the global
financial crisis was oh my gosh look at
all these prime age men who are not
working
right right we were all falling 25 to 54
25 to 54.
right so this recession has more
significantly impacted women and we see
that in the data but we also have
surveys that show that women
are spending more hours on child care
compared to prior to the pandemic than
men
are during the recession right on our in
these surveys right sure
and here's an interesting claudia
golden's policy recommendation by the
way to solve this problem of this
pay gap is to to offer and make sure
they take
to offer men paternity leave and time
off
and encourage them to take it when we
look at countries that do that and
chiefly at sweden and norway sure you
don't have as much of a gender pay gap
because men
are also taking time off from their
careers to do things for their families
and it's
normalized it's not stigmatized and so
um you don't see as much of a
of a pay gap so so i laud all those
parents who are taking time to
to focus on their children um you know
all the time but especially during the
pandemic and and we do see
the women finding it more difficult
to to create space to go back to work
until we have child care and education
back online
and and we hope i mean actually i i
follow this usa today
of all of all sources but they have a
map of the united states can i tell you
when i was traveling constantly and you
know how every hotel has a usb today
i they do great great reporting actually
i have they do true reporting yeah and
it's hard to i mean as a member of the
fourth estate that my second degree
at columbia was in journalism um but as
a member of the fourth estate i've got
to agree with you
but their coveted map of the united
states
has been one of my key go-to's i mean
several months ago and it's very simple
either the state is either the state is
purple or the state is blue if it's
purple cases are rising if it's blue
cases are
falling pretty simple and several months
ago
there were 40 states with rising case
counts
at last check there were three yeah
vaccinations are really working
and i think that i'm no scientist i'm no
epidemiologist but i think a lot of the
younger kids running around
have had coveted we don't know it
because for having the
percentage of vaccinations that we've
had we seem to be achieving hurt
immunity
at a at a lower threshold than what we
were initially
told was going to be the case given 45
some odd percent of americans
have been have been vaccinated so um
which which brings me to the rest of the
world
yeah the rest of the world uh
you you write about
kind of the dm em the develop market
emerging market
the divide and when you look at the
vaccination rollout on some of these
emerging markets
it's covid's not and and i think we have
this kind of myopia in the united states
because we're sitting next to each other
without mass and we're
vaccinated and life is different on the
other side of that
but i think we have a lack of
appreciation for how long
a lot of countries are going to be still
mired
in the pandemic we have billions of
vaccines to manufacture i mean
if even if we just want 50 of the world
vaccinated right with billions of
vaccines to manufacture
and and in every jurisdiction where the
vac
where the where in every jurisdiction
where
the pandemic is still running wild you
have it it has the opportunity to mutate
and to grow and become stronger right
and we've seen that it has mutated
um in in multiple cases right we see
different variants and different
strains we're seeing it play out one
country at a time in
asia and very very very sad
and they're trying to you know they're
trying to put the singapore taiwan japan
now they're talking about canceling the
olympics again
so we have to get vaccinations out um
and
and when we think about emerging markets
i would say there's two strikes against
them so you mentioned
the thought we were talking about the
fallout of artificial intelligence
[Music]
if you have a country that is not highly
educated right
you're gonna fall a little bit behind
once we can once this
artificial intelligence continues to
roll out right it will hurt countries
with
lower educated populations uh so
we have that plus the plus kovid are two
sort of significant strikes against
emerging markets and honestly
if the developed world wants to fully
recover
they are going to have to the g20 is
going to or the un
or the world bank or somebody is going
to have to consortium is going to have
to make sure
that we get these vaccinations to these
emerging markets but just from a
production i mean
billions of vaccines that need to be
produced
it's it's enormous and um you know when
you think about
when you think about some of the
societal changes
that have occurred retirees in america
used to be jumping on cruise ships 4.6
trips per year to international
i mean the global travel and tourism
industry
accounted for one in ten jobs worldwide
prior to the pandemic and a lot of these
emerging markets
depend heavily on international visitors
who are not going to
go there with the exception of mexico
which i can attest to
they're just not going to go there until
they feel like the facts
the viruses is controlled
yes i i mean it's it's it's a big
challenge
it is a it is a big challenge and this
is why we have global institutions right
this is why we have global coordination
and you know it doesn't always seem like
it's necessary if everything's going
well
but you get a you get a crisis and you
start to see
how really integral this is to the to
the healthy functioning of the global
economy
um so we'll get there we will get there
um we're probably probably at least a
year out on that though and that and i
do say that this is the arbiter the
the virus is the arbiter of the pace of
growth right so
it we have flare-ups in in countries
that are key suppliers of key
input materials it's going to impact us
it's going to impact the global economy
right for sure so their remains even
though we're having this fabulous
recovery and i think
there are a lot of positive things that
can happen over the next decade with
regard to technology
and productivity there is this tail risk
of the virus still out there
and it's a fat tail that was my that was
my fat tail
so so that that brings us to uh
to the subject of
what are your because you're you're very
you're sanguine on the outlook
and i'm happy that you're saying one on
the outlook i'm i tend to be a glasses
half empty person when it comes to
economics but that's that's ptsd from
work at the fed
it's you never get over it um but what
are the risks
yeah so and what are the risks
domestically
i think while i do and we were talking
about the disequilibrium
and i think it is going to be transitory
there is a chance and it's a not
insignificant chance so it's it's again
another fat tail risk so i think all the
tail risks we have now are pretty fat
right so they could be
pretty they're not my base case but
they're there and i'm watching them very
closely
so we are starting to see
expectations of future prices and some
of the longer-term measures the
five-year the 10-year
university of michigan surveys creeping
up now this happened
coming out of the global financial
crisis when we saw commodities rise so
so if we just look at the one-year
expectations that moves with the
commodity
commodity index it's a one-on-one
relationship and people
anchor to things that they buy every day
right so if you're buying
you're buying food or once a week you're
buying food you're going to anchor ah my
food prices are up 20
it's like yes but you probably only
spend
at most 10 or 15 of your budget on food
right maybe five right it's not a big
part of your basket
so um people tend to anchor to the
things they buy every day
and you look at something like used cars
for example use cars as one of the few
indices that does not trend so most
things get more expensive over time
right like if you look at a you look at
the chart over decades of that
of any other index whether houses
furniture
you know it just right goes up
uh used cars goes up goes down goes up
goes down goes up sure that'll that'll
they'll fall
those used cars prices will fall
eventually there was you know again
another perfect storm we had all the
we'd all the rental companies sell their
cars
and so there was a glut and then there
was and then there was a lack of supply
against the demand so there there are
things that
we can see for sure will be transitory
but the thing that i think is
interesting
is that we do see expectations for
longer-term inflation now starting to
tick up
and you know what if we get stronger
growth if we get higher productivity
right we could have inflation really
being sustained closer to 2.2 percent
on the other hand higher productivity
means that we can grow at a faster pace
without igniting inflation right
right um but but this this
this issue with prices i think is a
significant significant risk
it's again not my base case but it's a
risk and
and of course in order for higher prices
to be sustained we're going to need
wages to go up
now here's something that's interesting
when we when the pandemic first started
there was tons of economic research that
got produced like right away like
economists were
collaborating and looking at history and
so there was a great paper that talked
about
they talked about past pandemics and it
went back to sort of the black plague
and obviously not the best economic data
available for all of those
all of those centuries right but but
still to get a sense of
how did people respond how did economies
respond
and what's interesting is that you saw
pretty uniformly wages would go up
real wages would go up after the after
pandemics and it it was assumed that
this was
mostly attributable to loss of
population due to death
and and so you you had fewer workers
right economy comes back and those
workers started to earn more money
now what's what's very interesting about
this pandemic is you're starting to see
workers demand higher wages
right in the face of not being in full
employment now whether those demands
will be met is a whole other thing
but one of the refrains i hear from the
ceos i talk to
you see it in all the survey data is
that the price of labor has gone up that
it's hard to find workers
and so it is it's going to be very
interesting to look back at this
pandemic and really do a post-mortem
if if wages go up what the cause of that
is because i wonder if there is
something endemic in pandemics
that causes people to just have a bit of
a higher reservation wage
well you know it's uh what's been kind
of remarkable
is that we have seen for decades the
labor force participation rate for
workers 55 and older rising it's just
it's just been a steady and now we know
we have we've got the data we've we've
heard from social security
we've had a wrap just a rash of
retirements
millions of people have left the
workforce that that
they may come back if we have a long
expansion
they may come back but we also had asset
prices
move up so right unlike the global
financial crisis where by the way you
saw labor force participation of prime
age workers that 25 to 54
fall you saw the labor force through the
through the recession you saw the labor
force participation of the 55s just
continue to go up
yeah right but the baby boomers were ten
years younger
two true true but but they lost assets
during that
recession whereas if you have assets
you've
probably gained assets during this
recession so you maybe feel like you can
retire
um it'll be interesting to see if that's
permanent retirement or what happens
with that
well so you're you're talking around
monetary policy i am
interest rate sensitive sectors we've
seen housing do
house prices are a whisper away
from their all-time highs but the
utility of your home has gone up right
so the preferences
of people's preferences and the
importance they're attaching to their
home has gone up so a number of firms
like
are saying we're not ever going to go
back to being in the office five days a
week
it's we're going to have three days a
week so now you're
permanent you if that's if that stays
the case which
i'm not 100 sure it will but let's say
that jamie diamond would push
back but yes yeah yeah if that stays the
case
the utility that people need and this is
economists speak right but the utility
that people need
from their houses has now gone up so
people want more out of their house
okay and then there's the multi-family
aspect we're still seeing permits and
multi-family go
through the roof and we have record the
only other woman i've ever interviewed
on down the middle is
ivy zellman and we just went down
just deep into housing and one of her
concerns one of her fat tail risks is
that she's seeing
unprecedented levels of multi-family
units coming online this year next year
and yet permits keep rising so there is
definitely
a disconnect there's an imbalance
in the housing market and we don't know
back to the fed what retirees are going
to do
with their homes if stocks don't
levitate
indefinitely you know these are all
factors that need to be taken into
consideration right
but if they do come back right if they
do come back into the labor market
that would theoretically then give the
fed more room
because you'd have more people coming
into the labor market that would help
keep a lid on wages
that would help reduce the transmission
of
temporary high prices into permanent
high prices
um so it would be a really good thing um
you know and this is why they say
they're data dependent because
and and it's interesting this shift to
we're going to wait until we see it in
the data
is is a sh people talk about the you
know the
the average inflation targeting but it's
really about we're going to wait till we
see
evidence of it in the data before we
start materially raising rates that i
think
is the very interesting
switch because
you have to get very granular on what
the forward-looking data is
in order not to be caught back footed
so if there's a
a unique refrain the european central
bank came out with its financial
stability report
and again being a former fed insider
you don't start narratives accidentally
no you don't there was no mistake that
lail brainerd was
the author effectively of the financial
stability report
significant declines in asset prices and
and then you see all the regional fed
presidents
also talking about financial instability
and now you're hearing
other central banks talk about financial
and speed
this is not by accident no it's not
they're concerned and they should be
we want them to be concerned don't we
well we
we want them to be aware we do want them
to be concerned and be aware but
typically when the fed recognizes
something it's
almost post-facto well fair enough
so it's to me at least i
i'm wondering because at this point
it it feels like if the fed tightens
then they're going to bring asset prices
down and it feels like if the fed
ignores this extremely disruptive albeit
transitory
inflation that that's going to be
disrupted do you see
the fed as being in a corner
so i'm going to you're driving down the
highway
it's the highway and you're going maybe
65 miles an hour you're
going pretty fast and you see a ways
away
maybe maybe like a quarter mile away you
see some red lights ahead of you and
you're like i'm gonna need to slow down
so you could
put on your brakes but you're going
going 65 miles an hour you could just
take your foot off the brake
and let the car slow so that by the time
you get to that ac that accident and
those red lights you just tap on the
brakes
and the car slows you don't have to slam
on the brakes
and i think that's what the fed's going
for they're going for we're just going
to take
just take our foot off the accelerator
and let it
let it slow down now i do think
this transitory inflation we're seeing
this year due to supply bottlenecks and
this disequilibrium
they almost have to ignore that
because as i said nothing cures high
prices like high prices the high prices
themselves
we are reducing demand we completely
agree i mean you've got purchase
applications for homes
at a year low i mean well i don't think
anybody saw that coming
three months ago yeah well i mean you
really brought forward
probably two or three years of demand
into a compressed time frame
because of the pandemic and um
but so i guess your question is are they
backed into a corner
and i would say not yet that doesn't
mean they're not
going to be backed into a corner but
don't think they're backed into a corner
yet i still think they have room to
maneuver
i think they have room to sort of just
take their foot off that accelerator
slowly and let the
let the economy just slow down a little
bit
we'll see we'll see um so you've talked
a lot about
artificial intelligence machine learning
there's this one country that's a bit
ahead of us
how does china play into your
forecasting are they ahead of us though
are they uh well i mean
to take but one example and because
they've poured money into the sector
but wait i'm gonna i'm gonna push back
on that because
i'm a capitalist i believe in market
economies i think you're a capitalist
you believe in market economy
and what happens in market economies is
that
a lot of accidental events occur
right um companies fail
um things percolate up um
in a not pre-ordained fashion right and
it's
a little bit of chaos right a little
there's trade-offs the crisis can be
good
it can't right opportunity can come out
of crisis because we're because we're
anti-fragile and our institutions are
anti-fragile and they get better
but if you are
a centrally planned economy and you are
saying
this is what is going to be the winner
we're going to choose and we're going to
pour money into it
sure it could go up for a while but it's
not the same type of
organic process of competition
that we have in our economy that has
caused things to bubble up
to the top and i have to i really firmly
believe
that in the medium to long run that is
not the way to do this
that is not the way to to get ahead
which isn't to say
that government-sponsored r d which by
the way the u.s government did a great
deal of coming out of world war ii
well into the 60s and so um
and funded things that might not
otherwise have gotten funded of course a
lot of things failed but
but the way we funded was was through
our university system
and and and and the r d machine that our
universities are
and we allowed the um individual
inventors
to commercialize their invention and
profit from it
so that system is even though we did
fund
r d it's a very different system than
the chinese funding of r d
and i just so you think maybe i'm over
confident
maybe maybe i should be more worried and
more concerned
and i'm concerned about other aspects of
china and china in a geopolitical sense
for sure um
do i i'm not like a big eucliditis trap
person right that a rising power
automatically gets into a into a war
with the
with the existing hegemon predominant
power
it's a risk doesn't always have to
happen necessarily
but um but i do think there's some
geopolitical risks but i'm not
so worried from an economic perspective
so talk me out tell me why i'm wrong
tell me why you think that's
that i'm being too sanguine well
from from everything i've studied uh
greg ipaval people wrote a great uh
column a year ago or so that
basically put on a graph
telecommunications
providers worldwide and at the time
huawei was
33 of global telecommunications
equipment
and okay his basic premise was
as as the rest of the world ex-china
we need to do everything in our power to
make sure it doesn't get to 50
because once it does they're everywhere
once it does
they're in in they're listening to
everything well monopoly begets monopoly
too
right and they don't play by the rules
yeah
and that's i mean we're both friends
with leland miller yeah
and i've learned so much from him
over the years but it's the discipline
it's the long game it's
it's it's the fact that they're letting
companies default
at a faster rate than they ever have
it's almost a thing
for their economy it is but it's almost
as if they've taken a page out of
capitalism
and they've just started they decided to
start playing by the us rules
in in the post-war u.s era
so a couple of interesting things about
china
one is that if you look at the oecd
analysis
of where con where economies are
compared to their pre-covered
trajectories right so their trend we
are forecast to be above our trend by
the
third quarter of this year china is not
forecast to be above its previous trend
so covid
altered and accelerated i think
something that was already going to
happen given their demographics given
their debt profile sure
a lower potential gdp and they were
falling into people forget that global
trade contracted
year over year in 2019 yeah that was
largely a reflection look at chinese car
sales look at
look at how the decline in car sales
domestically within china
um so they were they were in a soft
patch
prior to the pandemic um
so so one they're not gonna grow as fast
as they used to grow and part it's a
base effect
right they've just gotten bigger um in
part their demographics are terrible so
if you look at what happened in japan
right they had their debt bubble burst
and then their population started
declining
from 1993 to now their population has
declined 0.3 percent
a year right their working age
population
china is having their working age
population decline it's very hard to
grow
when you're at a high rate when your
working age population has declined so
it all comes down to productivity i'm
coming into your camp now because
they're not an immigrant nation either
they're not an immigrant nation just
like japan's not an immigrant nation
right all right so i'm not saying that
they're not in
the the china is not a formidable
competitor that china's perception
of how they want to behave in the global
world order
is different than a western european u.s
centric
anglo-centric um mode of cooperation
right it's
that is a challenge and i mean there but
but when
when people when you hear people when
people say like oh china's beating us
it's like really
like like i mean you know you walk
through the streets of shanghai
and it looks very very shiny right you
you let's say you walk off the bond and
you just peer
you still see like someone carrying a
chicken
you know down the road and and there's
you know
water going into open sewers and it's
not
you know you just just peel back the
curtain a little bit
um so not to say that there's not
amazing technology
and amazing um uh
advancements that have come out of china
and certainly they've been able to
leapfrog like many emerging markets like
that's the whole that is the emerging
market story
right you technology that was developed
um in the western world they take
they take the technology they leapfrog
frog over all the development
and they're able to make faster leapfrog
moves because
they didn't have to develop the r d and
go through that long arduous process of
failure and success and
and all those trade-offs we were talking
about earlier and
so they leapfrogged in some regards and
when you look at sort of internet
banking right everybody
oh look at that i'll do internet banking
it's like yes but look at what happened
with ant financial the government was
like hold on a minute hold on
imagine you that's when the centrally
planned part comes back into the
equation and you're like oh wait they're
stopping economic growth
purposely well i mean i think that
there's a
there is a there's the right like let
regulation has a good you need some
regulation
you need some governance some corporate
governance
in place it allows laypeople to trust
right why do i why do i trust
the vaccine because we had regulation
around it we had
rules around it why do i trust putting
money at a bank or putting money at a
brokerage
because there's regulation around it
right i don't need to be an expert
but so you need some regulation but i
hear you
i hear your point though that things get
too big and they kind of they still are
trying to centrally control it and i and
i think if you
if you play that out if you play a
series of games right you have a bunch
of iterations
of that i don't
data history seems to suggest that that
is not
it it's a different trajectory it may
seem like a smoother trajectory
to get from point a to point b but i
think you fall short of point b
right so where's our trajectory it's not
as smooth but we're going to get to
point b
and we might might get there faster well
i i
you'll probably agree with me that i
hope that we put some serious money in
this country into infrastructure
i do we need to and and not just roads
and bridges right there's all different
types of
infrastructure that we have to invest in
well there i mean
i mean talk about leapfrogging not
everybody in america has access to the
internet i mean this is i mean
it's yes that is not that is not
acceptable
and if we are going to enter this age
where
artificial intelligence and machine
learning become a general purpose
technology
our best money spent can be on making
sure that we have
um appropriate technological literacy
among our population um
debt who's debt
which debt corporate debt corporate
balance sheets
corporate bond bailout by the fed uh
what we
didn't accomplish in terms of creative
destruction
in the aftermath of the pandemic
so you know we did a deep dive on a few
chart books back on zombie firms right
because
and it as someone who invested for most
of my career and spent a lot of times
investing in emerging markets right like
the
you know looking at these debt cycles is
something i i do
very closely so we were looking at this
rise of zombie farms and we're like
let's peel back the onion
all right i'm going to ask you a
question which firms
dominate the zombie what sector
dominates the zombie firms in the u.s
i would probably have to say telecom
telecom was prior to 2002. it is now
healthcare
you're right yes it is now yes and it
is um and it is there's a lot of biotech
and sort of emerging
technology in there so i have i i sort
of had a theory about this
and and and this isn't always the case
like if your zombie firms are banks
your economy is screwed mm-hmm right so
japan right there zombie friends were
banks
there was no lending that happened we
can't have our banks be zombie firms and
we cleaned our i mean we
look at europe right i mean what a mess
yes you're italy
huge number of zombie firms or banks
right that is that is
absolutely not a good situation because
you
you just retired financial intermediate
so there's an economist named carlotta
perez and she is an expert on technology
cycles
and one of the things she talks about is
you almost need a little bit of a bubble
to get a technology cycle going because
you're investing in this hair-brained
you know r d and so we saw this
obviously in the dot-com bubble right
right so we saw this huge investment
we saw crazy valuations and that's where
the zombie firms
lived those got cleaned out during the
recession
as we approached the global financial
crisis it was healthcare firms
that were becoming the dominant zombie
firms
some of them got cleaned out and now
here we are in the kova crisis and in
the intervening decade
or so we just saw an increase in the
number of zombie firms that were in the
healthcare space
and so obviously if your zombie firms
are in banking
right that's a huge problem for your
economy right you don't have financial
intermediation
japan after their bubble burst europe
after the global financial crisis
yeah exactly and this is different
and i'm not saying it's not problematic
but i don't
see it as so much of a systemic risk
to the economy it may hold back
some medical technological innovation
but i also you look at the breakthrough
that we've had not just in in harnessing
rna technology for vaccination
but in the streamlining of the fda
process i don't think we're ever going
to go back
to the previous fda process yes
streamlined now so
i'm not saying i'm not concerned and i'm
not saying there aren't going to be
certain sectors
where you see fallout but when i peeled
the unback and saw that
healthcare was the nexus of the zombie
firms
i was a surprise but also relieved
right so um do i think that there could
be a wave
of uh corporate bankruptcies sort of if
you fast forward
what is it two and a half years three
years rates start going up it's too much
for some companies to handle of course
but that's healthy creative destruction
and better that it happened
during an expansion where rates are
going up then
of course right after a recession right
i mean so i think i
i'm not i'm not saying we're not going
to see some some bankruptcies
but i don't necessarily think it's going
to bring us to our knees or
stop the expansion necessarily and
that's going to keep your productivity
going
well the productivity will also help
right like if we can really diffuse
productivity to these firms then that
should that should help them
get on stronger footing uh so
one last question i i consider myself to
be extraordinarily privileged
philippa dunn ellen zentner michelle
meyer
you but i'm finished counting oh
i can i i can help you count
i can help you so there are there are
too few women
in really high positions as economists
so now there's some who are not going to
be able to come on the media but the the
chief economist at gm is a woman
the chief economist at ford is a woman
totally by coincidence
um that the two largest automakers are
both women but both excellent economists
they're not going to do media
sure um but there's do you know julia
coronado
i do okay so she's someone yep there
there's my five so actually i
i i yep i can go past one hand now
but we do need more women in economics
we do need more women and i'll tell you
nabe is working on that
we launched a diversion
diversity and inclusion committee when i
was
president and it is only growing
in and sort of enthusiasm and activity
and i think it comes down to pipeline
right like not everybody can have
what i had where i was actually inspired
of course to consider this as a career
and i'm so thankful i also grew up in a
household where my parents were like you
can do whatever you want you can do
anything you want
right it was never like what do you mean
you want to do that my parents my dad
was thrilled
right that this was something i was
interested in that that's why i'm
excited that we're
starting to do space exploration again
because children are going to be
naturally
inspired yeah just to see this so
reaching down in and getting
getting pipeline is really really
important so nabe
i think has a unique um opportunity
because we have
the we have we've college uh name
memberships
and we have the certified business
economist designation that we do in
partnership with universities
now we just need to go down one layer
even lower and go down into the
sort of high school level and really
financial literacy
yeah really drive uh interest but i
think
you know it's interesting i'm also a
member of 100 women in finance
and um something that they found in
studying this problem was that a lot of
young girls and young women didn't
understand like if you're
a portfolio manager right in your let's
say you're you're managing a pension but
it's a teacher's pension or you
it's a nurses and doctors pension that
you're actually helping society by being
in finance
um that is an economist you're you're
helping firms make really good business
decisions
to help them grow and help them employ
people and and so
um you know having the awareness that
this is something you can do
that also feeds your soul i think is
is not how people would traditionally
think of a finance or an economics
profession but it but it absolutely is
and i
i have to say especially during the
pandemic right
there's a there was a community of
economists that really came together
men and women that that really made me
thrilled to be an economist like it was
so nice to see the collaboration
and the um just the camaraderie oh i
just thought of a couple of other women
so diane swonk diane swann diane swank
at grant thornton
um there are um i'm gonna forget her
last name there's some
women who are at a lot of the uh the
tech firms
who are really good economists i will i
will send you a list of names
or i'll i'll tweet i'll tweet out some
yeah we'll do a twitter
intro that's perfect because i they're
they're out there
constance i'm gonna have my daughter
watch this episode i am
i really appreciate you spending so much
time today great to see you in person i
happen we're both vaccinated i got to
hug you fantastic
let's do this again i would love it
thank you so much for having me this has
been a joy
thank you take care well i i thank you
once again for taking the time
uh and watching this this episode of
down the middle
constance is not only a good friend she
is
a constant check against my
confirmation bias if you will so i hope
you took good notes i hope you enjoyed
some of the charts that she put up and
uh and as i mentioned
i've recently spoke with ivy zellman and
she and i constance and i are
also good friends with leland miller if
if you've not seen those two episodes
i highly recommend you you do that and
and again if you haven't subscribed
please do so now i will see you next
time thank you